[Music]
get over it
I'm your new father-in-law
Thomas Merkel has some strong words for
Prince Harry my answer to the royal
family is that I'm Megan Markos bad
we're just a family now 73 year-old sat
down with the Sun on Sunday for his
second on-camera interview since Megan
and Harry's May 19th nuptials he told
the outlet he worries about his daughter
quote I think she is terrified I see it
in her eyes I see it in her face and I
see it in her smile this is a pained
smile plus Thomas said he's been unable
to reach Megan since their brief
conversation after the wedding
since the interview I've had no no way
of contacting or the phone number that I
called it doesn't work anymore and
there's no address I can write to so I
have no way of contacting my god what
would Marco like to say to his daughter
if he could my message would be I love
you an issue I'm sorry for anything that
went wrong I'd like to put our
differences behind us and get together
last month the source told ET that Megan
inheres relationship with Thomas is
fracture amid the unfolding family drama
Megan spent her weekend enjoying some
girl time with Kate Middleton marking
their first ever joint appearance
without their hubby's the Royal ladies
cheered on Angelique Kerber
and Marcos close friend Serena Williams
at the Wimbledon Championships
[Music]
you